hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
with you and one of the authors on my
website JP wrote in to me wanting to do
a podcast he has a podcast called the
flop factor this launching soon he said
when I joined him and I said I'd love to
why don't we also do it as a YouTube
hang out so I could introduce you guys
to him and you could also benefit from
the conversation so JP welcome aboard
and give us a little bit of an intro on
what the flop fact is all about ya know
very cool thanks you know the cool thing
about business and trying to achieve
anything whether it's be an athletics or
science or inventing or whatever is that
you're going to run up against
challenges you're going to run up
against mistakes failures I heard Ilan
most talking about the fact that you
know Tesla was started based on two
false assumptions but you know so
anytime you do something really great or
you're trying to achieve something
really great it you're going to hit
those roadblocks and over 26 years of
building companies I've run up my fair
share of them I've been you know so low
I could play handball on a curb so it's
I've got you know all those t shirts in
the closet of all the failures and
mistakes and things that I went through
but what I found was every time I looked
around and talk to other people that had
achieved success they also had their
stories and I started working on a book
called flop factor how to fail your way
to success and I started interviewing
some folks and I was like man you know
what we should just put these interviews
out as a podcast and so we've had a lot
of excitement building we're launching
the first of July so this one will come
out somewhere then probably the first
couple of weeks of July and you know a
lot of people are getting very very
excited about it I tell people you know
there's probably only two reasons
someone would listen to the show one
you're either bored and have nothing to
do or two you're going through some crap
in your life and need some inspiration
and need some a boost you know to get
over it i feel like this show is having
done as many interviews as we have so
far and knowing the folks that we have
on the roster coming already i think
this is going to be a real gift to the
world it's going to be a real gift to
people my belief in life is that the
more you give the more you get but you
got to give give give before you get
yep that's long all you can't overcome
that and this is just another way of
giving back and giving back to the
universe and paying forward so you know
if people want to win go over this later
but if people want to hook up with us
then go to flop factor calm and then
we're also hashtagging flat factor out
there and Twitter and such but yeah
it'll be out on video on YouTube and
some other places and it'll be so this
will be edited down and then it'll be in
audio in iTunes and stitcher and a few
other places like that so cool I'm
excited for the launch for those you
guys watching I've linked it up in the
description below so you can go check it
out and GP over to you man like run to
run the show like it's yours and I'm
excited let's do it sounds good so I've
got some some basic questions and we'll
go on and off script probably as we go
through this but what I'd like to start
out with I realize this is your on this
live show we're done a lot of people
know your story but when we come back
and start talking about your new folks
listening to flop actor people that
listen to this show once it launches you
know they may not know who you are or
what your background is or what you're
doing right now so what I want to start
out is talking about what are some of
the things that you're winning it right
now what are some of the cool things you
mentioned you doing I had no idea I knew
you're putting some serious content out
there I had no idea you were doing three
shows of there are three videos a day
that's just insanity but it's working I
mean I see your numbers climb and then
stuff that's been pretty cool but what
things are you winning at then once we
kind of lay that down a little bit we're
going to back up and talk about maybe
some of those experiences quote-unquote
those flops those setbacks or things
that you've had to overcome on the path
to where you are today sure I feel I'm
winning at anything I'm putting my heart
into I feel I'm winning anything and
putting my time and love and energy into
and it doesn't necessarily always yield
instant results but I still feel like
I'm winning because i'm learning in and
i'm having a lot of fun with it right
now where my time is being spent is on
the youtube channel so its daily
inspiration resources for entrepreneurs
we have three videos a day going up some
of it is my own advice based on my
experience and then also model and
success has been a huge theme in my life
as I built my companies so there's
lessons every day from different famous
entrepreneurs that you can learn from to
apply to your company that and I'm right
in the book
too so my book comes out this number six
is with penguin Random House and there's
as I'm sure you can appreciate a lot of
hard work that goes into making a book
and making that come true so a lot of my
time is being spent between the book the
website the youtube channel and yeah
it's a lot of fun can you talk a little
bit of it is there gonna be I see the
believe theme and a lot of the things
you're doing is it going to be around
that or is it something else what the
book yeah I haven't talked about the
book content yet it's coming it's coming
it's coming it's similar to some of the
stuff that I have been talking about so
it's not just like this insanely new
surprise that people won't expect but I
haven't released the content yet but
soon soon Before we jump into the the
flops or the challenges talk to me about
the guy in the back ground over there
once what's the history there this guy's
name Guan Yu he looks really little but
he's not it's just if I back up here
he's pretty like life-size almost half
of me um his name is gone you he is a
he's the god of war in China if you look
at chinese history and mythology why I
like him is he was this he was one of
the best warriors in China at the time
it was this huge guy way taller than any
other Chinese words at the time and any
weapon that they gave him would be no
problem for him to the use because he
was just so massive and he said you know
what instead of just using other
people's weapons I'm going to make my
own weapon and he's known if you look at
any of his statues he has this huge
thing called the Gwanda which is off of
his name and only he could carry it
because it was so heavy you needed a
behemoth of a man to be able to do it
and so he's known for having created his
wand ow weapon alongside would be in a
great warrior and it just reminds of
entrepreneurs like instead of just
living in the world that is there that
other people have created we Forge our
own weapon to go out and do something
that nobody else can do and do something
amazing so just having him here is a
constant reminder that I gotta be me I
gotta do me I gotta do what I'm really
good at and not worry about other
people's expectations of me that's very
cool
alright cool well I had to know because
it's like the only thing that's not
modern everything of nice and clean and
computerized and painted alright so
let's talk a little bit about if you can
take us back because people listening to
the show that are in an experienced what
they want to be able to do is relate and
to feel like okay maybe I'm not the only
one that's dealing with this take us
back to maybe some of your experiences
one or two or something that really
stands out for you and then let's walk
through that like the early days of my
first company that could be could be so
I thought I was going to be a banker I
never expected to be an entrepreneur was
not on my path my family there's no
entrepreneurs in my family I never
thought I was gonna be it you know high
school yearbook says I'm going to be a
VP at a bank in 20 years ten years and
so that was a path I was on I was pretty
happy with that path when I got
University I connected with two
entrepreneurs who had started a company
and they needed help and I thought it
was an interesting challenge to take on
you know why not and I became an owner
in this business and some of the hardest
days of my life living to me in that
company a lot of failure a lot of
struggle and the hardest decision I ever
had to make was I got opportunities to
work at Merrill Lynch and mackynzie and
you know 80 $100,000 starting salary and
fine around the world and all these
great you know perks that I thought I
always wanted and meanwhile i had this
company that was struggling and sucking
and i'm making three hundred dollars a
month and is not working in the logical
smart safe thing to do would have been
to go take the job but something inside
me just felt like i had to give this
business a trial like I would regret it
if I didn't try and that feeling i
formed the modern evan i guess where i
am today is that I try now not to do not
to not do things because i'm afraid i
try to fast-forward my life to when I'm
80 90 100 or 200 or however long we're
going to live these days and think will
I regret not making this decision like
if I don't
say yes to this am I going to regret it
down the line and I try to live my life
with as few regrets as possible and I
learned that in the early days of that
business the other foundational thing I
guess with with my business that has
helped carry me through to today is the
idea of modeling success anything that I
had previously applied myself to I had
success with in athletics in academics
anything and I got put the time in I'll
get better at and here was putting in
st. i'm into my company and it just
wasn't working nothing was working we're
just sucking constantly come within a
new idea that didn't work and you had to
what do you when you look back now what
do you think knowing what you know now
why do you think that those failures
were happening where you learn just
learning the ropes um are you figuring
out what doesn't work or what do you
think it was calm just a completely
wrong path yeah I think I just didn't
know enough and I was trying to come up
with every idea myself I thought I had
to come up with everything myself every
new idea wasn't looking to other sources
and that led to the genesis of modeling
success and I asked myself hey I'm not
the first guy to try to sell software
before like somebody has figured this
out I gotta figure out who that is and
model them and that's where I learned
the bell bill gates's story and how we
started Microsoft and not how Bill Gates
makes an extra million dollars now
that's not interesting but zero to one
right I wanted to do that how did he do
that and it was through partnerships in
his case and I modeled that strategy and
started landing deals and finally had
some momentum and since that worked
anytime I approach a new challenge I
always ask myself who has done this how
can I model some success right like hey
I'm going to start a YouTube channel who
can I model or if I'm starting the
podcast who's already done this instead
of always trying to come with everything
yourself yes there's absolutely room for
creativity you can't just copy what
somebody else does but it's taking what
has worked and put in your own
uniqueness on it making it into the wand
out for yourself that that along with
not living life with regrets or two of
the core lessons that I learned from
from my first business going back
those actually counted them i think you
said a lot of failures a lot of
struggles so it's like eight words it
it's easy for entrepreneurs because well
I've said this to many people I'm
eternally optimistic and I would rather
not talk about negative stuff so I don't
know if others are like that but I just
rather not dwell on it I just really go
do something successful and and just
keep moving forward like you focus on
what I learned from that etc but take us
back a little bit inside those eight
words what was the experience like
because you said it felt like no matter
what you tried like what was the
emotional thinking what was what was
going on at that time as you lived
through that what was it like to live
through that uh I'll do my best because
I am with you and I block it out there
you have to block it out like if you
spent him like there's so much crap at
the sort of a business you have to block
it out or or it's over I think for me it
was very lonely I had nobody to talk to
with my own fault you know I I had
turned down these high paying jobs that
my friends all wanted to go do my own
thing and I was supposed to be living
the entrepreneur lifestyle I mean while
I couldn't do anything I couldn't afford
anything right like my friends invited
me out to go for beer and birthday
parties and watch a movie and I I'm
making three hundred dollars a month
like I had to pick one thing per month
that I could do because that's all I can
afford because 20 bucks was a huge deal
and I would always tell them that I'm
too busy i'm working on these deals and
just yeah I guess the ego takes over and
I didn't want to I didn't want to be
embarrassed in front of my friends
turning down those jobs and here I was
like not being successful and so I would
have to kind of plan out okay like whose
birthday is coming up this month or
what's the one thing that I can do this
month and that really sucked like that
takes a huge beating on you and it's my
fault too like I'm sure my friends would
have been understanding and accepting if
I told most having her
time I just felt like I had to be the
man and I couldn't show that weakness I
guess you know we I beans for lunch
every day I had the same thing for lunch
I ate a canned beans put some olive oil
and salt on it and that's what i ate
every day for months a year maybe more
we would celebrate a win we got a new
order that came in we would go to
McDonald's and sit there in McDonald's
and just get french fries like not a
meal just french fries because that's
all we could afford and mcdonald still
has kind of like a happy place in my
head even though it's really bad for you
because like the McDonald's fries were
sign that something good was happening
but again it's all we could afford and I
wasn't really complaining in that moment
it wasn't like uh you know there was
still the optimism there was still the
positivity like I think we can make it
through but but it took its toll on me
emotionally in that again prior
everything I had done I knew that if I
work harder at it if I if I ran and
train I could do yeah I think I could do
a better time in my next sprint right
like it everything that I try to
practice my jump shot I get better
basketball and it just it seemed like
everything I was doing just wasn't
working and and it was just insanely
frustrating and and one of the worst
days of my life boiled over when I was
at a family event as up my parents house
and my partner and i were disagreeing
over where we should go what's the
direction like what are we doing and
when you're making money it's easy to be
on the same page when you're not making
money it's like you're you're grasping
at straws just trying to hang around and
we have a disagreement over what we
should do I don't remember what I wanted
to do versus him and I just got off the
phone and at the end of the conversation
I said I I quit like I can't do this
anymore I'm tired of feeling worthless
like I'm tired of feeling like the time
that I'm spending is not doing anything
positive I need to feel valuable somehow
out doing something and I can't do this
business anymore because it's just
pounding me down on my self-worth and
self-esteem too much and I you know I
hung up the phone and and then I just
started crying like uncontrollably the
the the most I've ever cried in my life
stuff coming out of my nose just like
terrible and my mom came up and she put
her hand in my shoulder and she heard me
crying from that from you know
downstairs and I don't remember what she
said to me uh just you know kind of
soothing mom talk i guess but didn't
really help that much barely slept that
night and and then I just thought I
gotta find the way like I can't quit
hearing me say I quit is not cool like
it's such a core foundation than Who I
am that I thought I just I couldn't do
it I don't know and so I just had to
find another way to do it and that's
where the idea of Mahlon success came in
because I hit rock bottom and I realized
I need to find another way to do this
and I showed up the next day to my my
partner's apartment we worked out of his
apartment I worked on the dining room
table because his then was too small for
us to be in and to his credit didn't
give me a hard time he opened the door
he just looked at me and he'd let me in
and we just got right to work where he
could have been like hey I thought you
quit on me man you know give me a hard
time and I was kind of getting ready for
it but to his credit he just opened the
door and we went back to work but that's
real like that happens every day across
the country people just feeling lack of
self-worth because they're not getting
results in their business and they end
up quitting and they quit too soon and
for me was just not having the right
knowledge not knowing what to do I
thought I knew I thought I knew
everything you know like you're in
University you think you have all the
answers I thought I knew everything and
I obviously didn't and the modeling
success became the path that started to
turn the business around that's awesome
and thank you for going deeper because
then that's the real story that that's
beautiful so let's talk about that path
out when you when you say modeling
success you mentioned Bill Gates
looking for like I used to do this weird
thing I had a board of directors in my
some of my darkest hours i had a board
of directors that was a virtual board
and it was like people that I admired
wayne Huizenga was on that board of
directors Richard Branson was out of
that board of directors and I used to
like literally have these meetings with
myself and my virtual board thinking
what would they do because I'd read
their books multiple times I'd watched
every interview or you know listen to
every interview whatever I could get my
hands on you tube is such a blessing now
because we get so much more and even
what you're in summarizing success in
multan is amazing but back then a lot of
those early days that didn't even exist
the internet didn't exist back when I
was doing a lot of this stuff but but if
you if you look at at what you did
modeling success and coming out of that
how did you make that application like
what were you reading a book and you go
okay I'm gonna try this what was the
path out sure uh I was not an avid
business reader when I was younger when
I had this company I was not I wasn't
reading biographies I wasn't following
trends I wasn't looking at websites in
when I was university the internet was
just starting to come up and so I know I
was still going to libraries to and I
remember what it was like checking out
books and doing research at a library it
sounds crazy now for me so I think I
mean I think you started a bunch of at a
point like having I didn't have a
virtual board of directors I didn't know
about Branson and jobs and these guys
and what they had done maybe I might
know their names but I didn't know their
story at all it was that realization
that hey I'm not the first guy to try to
figure this out somebody must have done
this I need to find out a solution and
I'm red I just thought about Microsoft
because we were a software company there
was no big we're in biotech software
there's no big biotech software company
to model at the time and so I said okay
who's the biggest software company in
the world Microsoft great how do
microsoft get started it was really that
like basic how did Microsoft get started
and and Bill Gates did it through
partnerships their big deal came with
IBM when
every IBM sold IBM was the biggest
computer maker in the world at the time
every IBM sold had Microsoft software on
it and that exploded the company but
Microsoft was already a seven million
dollar company when they meet that deal
with IBM now 7 million is not a huge
company but it's 7 million more than
what I had so I something like go deeper
and how they got the 7 million was still
through partnerships so finding people
who already had their customer base and
find a way to ally with them somehow to
get the software out there so they're
okay that's cool i'm gonna i have
nothing else to lose i almost quit
already you know why don't I try this
partnership thing and within a couple
weeks I landed my first partnership with
a company in Europe who was going to
distribute our software and I got them
to pay 13 and a half thousand dollars in
advance to be our exclusive distributor
for that market and to me 13 and a half
thousand dollars ok looks like 300 a
month right LMK 13 and a half thousand
yeah I'm making bank like that's the
best day of my life you know that that's
a serious deal that doesn't sound like a
lot now but man back then that was that
was insane and more important than just
closing that one deal I had a I had a
path to do more like I could do that
again that's only one deal like I can
replicate that many many times over and
so by forming a bunch of different
partnerships were able to rapidly scale
and grow the company and was just so
that I didn't try before I didn't think
about it myself and learning that that's
what propelled Bill Gates's success of
Microsoft forward that that inspired me
and I tried it and it worked now I had
to put my own little twist that to make
it my own quanda but that's what helped
kind of saved that first business and
ever since so that's why you know the
YouTube channel is called mauling the
Masters it's why a lot of the content is
from studying these famous people
successful people what worked for them
and hopefully a little bit of their
magic pixie dust rubs off onto you and
starts changing your mindset and
approach and attitude so yeah I mean
Bill Gates save my I never Bill Gates in
my life but he saved my business he's
safely business that's very interesting
you
I do want to take an aside because in
the show we stay very I don't want to
say philosophical because we do get into
the nitty-gritty and some tactical stuff
but you did talk about something that
that partnerships I call it marketing
leverage as long as I we're on the same
thing I believe we were all in the same
thing I first learned about that from
Jay Abraham yours many many many years
ago and I used that over and over and
over again when I was building our
private label training company we were
dealing with associations of franchise
companies and I would go in and you know
we would make a deal with them to
basically distribute throughout their
the organization we private label our
videos and stuff but over the years I've
used what i call marketing leverage what
you're talking about is partnerships I
think that's one of the the hidden gems
of bootstrapping a company and I think a
lot of folks that are watching this show
and experience in this are going to be
in that in that vein there bootstrapping
or else they're trying to to get to the
next level and they're really struggling
trying to find the way around the
roadblocks for you what is the how do
you put your sort of I call it a JV
sixth sense joint venture sixth sense or
whatever but how do you put on your
sensors or what do you look for when
you're thinking about a partnership that
will give you that kind of leverage yeah
absolutely uh first of all I love Jay
brahim I discovered him again later in
life and I wish I knew about him earlier
because a lot of his lessons can be
applied to any business for me it's
thinking about who already has my target
audience so Who am I trying to reach if
I'm trying to in that in that business I
was trying to reach researchers at at
universities and researchers at
biotechnology companies so who is
already selling to those guys and who is
selling a product that is not
competitive with what I'm selling now
there are ways to work with your
competitors but I was trying to focus
specifically on people who are selling
complimentary things and the idea is
pretty simple is that instead of you
having to talk to people one at a time
me customer talk
one of the time one item at a time
you're talking to someone who can
introduce you to dozens of customers or
hundreds or thousands of customers at a
time it's a much higher leverage
conversation and they've already built
up the relationship and all the work so
that you know coming to them from a
respected name that they already know is
way easier than you trying to open the
door yourself and so for your listeners
people trying to do this for themselves
clearly identify who is your target
audience who are you trying to read
through the ideal clients that you want
to have in your business and then who is
already selling to them some kind of
complimentary service and you can look
at it is the best ones are the people if
you look at a buying cycle you know if
I'm if I'm buying any product you go
through different phases and along those
steps there's different people that you
buy from look at who are they buying
from before they buy from you so before
they buy your product what else are they
buying first and then go talk to those
guys who are selling those products and
services and find a way to make an
alliance there's a different way there's
a million different ways to skin a cat
is tons of different ways to form an
alliance whether you're giving a
commission for helping you whether
you're just promoting each other on
their websites whether you're
interviewing them for your podcast at
your website a lot of different ways to
do it and most people are open to having
the conversation because they see it as
a two-way street too but you can send
people to them as well it's way easier
to open up a partnership kind of call
meeting coffee then a sales call to a
customer and it's much higher leverage
if you get the right person so just
starting with who already has my target
audience and then how can I make an
introduction to them and learn about
what they what they're trying to do like
before you start pitching what you do
and how you can help you have to listen
to them to see what they're trying to do
right then you can tailor your pitch
towards what they actually need and
maybe you can't help them like maybe
this doesn't work maybe it's just
somebody that you keep in mind that
maybe feature this some kind of
connection that you can make I think
people get also in to pitch mode too
early without using the best tool which
is your ears to listen to what they're
trying to do and see how you might be
able to help them know it's also
did you where was the transition for you
you said you want a big reader and all
that before when did the transition come
of really studying success and modeling
success so before I I was a reader but I
read fiction you know I was a big
Michael Crichton fan and read all
Jurassic Park and all of those books it
started with with that realization that
I don't have all the answers and I want
to find someone who does and Bill Gates
was the only guy that I knew how to
software company so I started reading
him and as I learned from him then I
started reading about other people and
what they were up to and realized hey
any problem that I have somebody has
already solved it I just got to modify
it to fit for me and so from then on I
became an avid fan of reading
biographies and then as the internet
became more popular trying to watch
videos trying to watch interviews trying
to watch speeches of people were given
commencement addresses people were
giving to try to learn a little bit more
and the more you hear the message from
different people the more it starts to
sink in deeper and you start to change
your mind sets and your beliefs and your
attitudes but it all started with that
like rock bought a moment where I
realized that I did not have the answers
and I want to find someone who does yeah
yeah did you ever watch the movie
pirates of Silicon Valley I did it's
been a while but yeah I did it's a good
movie to watch but for years as a
keynote speaker like one quote that I've
quoted out of that movie it's it's when
the character playing Steve Jobs is on
stage doing like at a Mac world or
something he's doing a speech typical
reveal or whatever and the character
that plays Bill Gates is standing off in
the the curtains and he speaks to
someone next to him and that's his quote
I've never forgotten it he said success
is a menace it fools smart people into
thinking they can't lose and I think
that I've never forgotten that and it's
so appropriate for the flop vector
because the moment you think that you've
got it all down and you mentioned you
were in University at the time and you
know young and so intelligent you know
everything or whatever but
um different people arrived at that
moment at different times and if you
ever ride arrive at that moment where
you think you got it all figured out and
got it all dialed in life just seems to
have a way of bringing you back to
reality and I think that's very
interesting so let's talk a little bit
about any particular books or mentors or
anything that I know you run the gamut
with your youtube channel and that sort
of thing but is there anything that has
been very meaningful to you in some of
your most challenging times even in in
later years when you run up against
something you go oh boy this helped me
get over that anybody any authors any
books any particular thing sure the the
book that I was a go-to for me for years
was called radicals and visionaries
Superunknown book put up by entrepreneur
press and it's out of print now we're
basically it was it did a lot of what
I'm doing on my youtube channel right
now it was stories of famous and
successful entrepreneurs in three pages
hello every every morning I'd like get
to the office and I would read three
pages about Michael Dell or about Steve
Jobs or about Oprah Winfrey or what were
they a lot of people I even know first
time exposure to them to the book and
just seeing where they came from I got
both motivation that I realized hey I'm
already starting from a place that was
better than when where most of these
guys came from so I don't have any
excuse if they could do it and to gave
me some practical strategies on what I
could do like oh this is how Oprah did
it this is how Michael Dell did it and I
started saying how can I apply that to
my business and I would start my day
every day with that now I'm use YouTube
like I love my own channel i created my
channel for me I think we talk about
success and how it can like knock you
back down I think the success can also
lead to complacency I reached the point
in my life where I had had success and
everybody around me was just saying I
wish I could have success like that you
know you did such a great job and it's
it's very humbling it's a great problem
to have but there was nobody in my life
saying Evan you know you've done good
but like you should be up here you're
still playing small like what you've
done is really nothing it's a little bit
okay but you got to be playing weight
bigger like there was no
in my life challenging me like that in a
supportive way and so I created the
series that i have on youtube for me to
watch every day because when i look at
what jobs is doing and Branson was doing
in all of these successful people I feel
like man I still got a big mountain to
climb and it's motivating and exciting
for me and so at the start I was
learning just some entrepreneurs and my
audience has taken me to learn from a
lot of different people um actors
athletes politicians you know Denzel
Washington we did a great video on and
then surprising you know I've seen some
of his movies but it's surprising how
much advice and inspiration he can
provide to and so the channel has
expanded to learn from anybody who's has
success because my goal is not to be the
next Steve Jobs of the next Richard
Branson or the next Denzel Washington is
to be the best me and should be the goal
for you know you all your listeners you
can't there's no perfect person out
there so you learn a little bit from
everybody you can learn just like your
board of directors right like absence it
might be how to be creative and how to
come up with some insane marketing
scheme to blow up your company right uh
but you may not want to learn from him
for other things right he's not very
detail-oriented so you don't want to
take that from him right so you pull
from Branson and jobs and all these
other people you pull from your parents
to you pull from you know if you're
religious you may pull from your pastor
you pull from the people in your
community to make you the best version
of you and so the channel what I'm
trying to do now is expose people to a
lot of different views and a lot of
people would they may not have ever
heard of before to allow them to become
the best version of themselves well
that's that's good good stuff so when
this airs as a well even live right now
but when this airs as a podcast someone
sitting there on the other side of
YouTube watching the video they're
listening to fought factor and iTunes
whatever it's really just them right
there alone they probably have their
headphones in the ear and they're
listening and they're watching what
would you say given an opportunity to
speak look them to
the I speak directly to their ear what
would you say to them to help them in
the moment that they're in right now to
be able to make some positive proactive
steps out of where they're at to move
forward the two things i would recommend
are one make sure the thing that you're
doing is something that you love that
you're absolutely passionate about the
reason why i couldn't quit that business
even though everything was against me
was I still loved it like I still wanted
to turn this thing around I had to find
a way and if you want to be doing
something that you would do even if you
weren't getting paid and it's of all the
people that we profile it's the most
consistent message that comes up over
and over and over and over again and
it's almost cliche at this point but
it's also very true that you have to do
the thing that makes you come alive and
if too many people don't too many people
are doing the things that they're bored
with that they may have some success
with but you'll never really rise to the
top until you do the thing that you
absolutely love the second part is
change your environment to support your
dream you can't do great things unless
you're surrounded by greatness so
listening to this podcast maybe that's
the answer right like listen to this
show how many times does it coming down
three times a week twice a week right
like new jobs a week three times a week
you know that could be a great service
for you JP is going to introduce you to
people every week that can change your
life right creative routine habits
structure so every day you have
something that pushes you to want to do
more because if your parents aren't
doing it and your friends aren't doing
it and the people around you aren't
doing it stop blaming that like it's on
you it doesn't matter what country
you're in or what disability you might
have or what your educational background
is there are people who have done way
more got way further ahead who had less
than you do right now and so taking
responsibility for your life for your
dream and create an environment that
supports that bigger picture thinking I
think it's critical so love what you do
create a great environment that's
awesome when um
and when people want to get obviously
you've got the channel and you got the
secret book coming out that you won't
talk about the secret day that's a great
you should call it the secret back I
just thought of that but uh yeah the
this book that this elusive titled an
elusive topic the book that's going to
be amazing and change people's lives and
I have confidence because if you know
folks look at your website that you owe
your own content and things you have a
lot of others to put out and then look
at what you've done on YouTube that's
great what would be the best place for
people to jump off into the world of
Evan Carmichael ah youtube was really
spending most of my time so is the
easiest place but I'm in other places
too you know whatever your favorite
place is Facebook or Twitter you can
just just look for Evan Carmichael to
find it but my home my heart my passion
is on youtube at the moment all right
fair enough and so we're going to finish
up I'm gonna get you to do since we're
liable to get you do the shout out later
we'll do that and I'll get you shoot
that over to me any last words that
you'd like to leave folks with before we
finish up positive word of encouragement
a quote anything that's meaningful that
you think you'd like to leave folks with
yeah i would say uh maybe it's a bit of
twist i would say be grateful and show
appreciation for the people who are
making an impact on your life you know
like if you're listening to the flop
factor right now and this is this this
might be your first introduction to JP
or maybe you've heard all of the
episodes leave a comment show some love
like share it on Twitter tell people
about it because it can be really hard
as a creator to put out a lot of work
and especially at the start you don't
get the praise and recognition even
though people are consuming it and
loving it and so if you want people to
continue to be a positive impact on your
life then tell them that you've had that
impact and so if you're loving this
episode tweet it out tweet 0 JP tweetup
me share it subscribe show gratitude for
the people who are having a positive
impact in your life awesome thanks so
much for being on the show and for doing
it on YouTube this was kind of fun I've
been recording these mainly on skype so
that we could read Leeson later but this
has been fun
kind of a neat different format so I
appreciate you hooking it up and your
system putting it all together thanks so
much heaven love it thank you guys like
ap thanks for watching do you want to do
what did you want me to do at the end I
get it now it's on all it is and it was
in the written questions but I'll read
it to you if you don't have them in
front of you it's I want you to give a
shout-out just basically hello this is
Evan karma karma karma go by com you're
listening to the flop factor how to
figure way to success on 430 calm so
holy cow it's long on what's and just
give a shout out of who you are and what
this is in flatbush com that's gonna
flop back to calm oh ok I should be
reading this I'm great off script but I
suck I'm okay at home let me put in let
me put out here we go I don't listen to
the chat where is let's see your worst
chat on this thing I had to do a video
with brian tracy that had a whole bunch
of stuff that i had to read and it was I
took so many takes okay uh or just make
it simple the pop factor how to feeling
reason okay hello this is Evan
Carmichael from ever comical calm and
you're listening to the flop factor how
to fail your way to success available at
flop factor calm one take there we go my
brother have a good one have a great day
and a great rest of the week take care
of thank you thank you guys for watching
continue to believe I will see you soon